so i guess do you want me to give you a
countdown
oh i was i was waiting for the countdown
uh are we are we
on air okay yeah sorry sorry um
yes sorry about that i thought uh you
were gonna minimize and then jump back
in but
i will give you a countdown now
okay sounds good starting in five
four three two
hi my name is sergey sedrakan i'm a
junior faculty at the
university of southern california and
children's hospital los angeles
i thank the organizers for this
invitation and the opportunity to
present
our work today i will talk about
extracellular vesicles and chronic
kidney disease
so what is chronic kidney disease it is
defined by gradual loss of renal
function
over a period of time sometimes it's
short sometimes it's relatively long and
there are many different factors that
contribute to the initiation progression
of chronic kidney disease and in the
population the two main ones being
diabetes and
cardiovascular problems in addition
obesity
genetic mutations tobacco use and aging
are also important factors that can lead
to progression
of chronic kidney disease
i will not exaggerate if i say that
kidney is one of the
you know most complex organs that we
know of and as it's very complicated and
heterogeneous in structure
hi sargents can you hear me
uh
i guess can you hear me
you've uh if you can hear me you've
frozen if you want to try
exiting the studio and re-entering
am i back yes there you are
yeah sorry i i didn't realize where
where did you lose me
exactly i believe it was towards the end
of slide
two so we could just do a fresh restart
if you want um
up to you i can start from slide two or
let's go ahead and start since you were
on slide two we're close enough
you're okay with that and then um we can
give it
another shot um
and then if anything comes up again i'll
let you know
yes so how uh what happened uh on my end
was that my slide started
changing without my touch
i didn't see your message actually uh
first i i saw my slides going haywire
uh then i realized i'm not uh something
is wrong
yeah i um i wasn't i figured you weren't
able to hear me so i thought maybe one
way to
get your attention was to move the
slides around so i see okay
that's that's a good way once yeah okay
okay well that's a that's a good way to
uh to
uh you know to wave the flag
okay perfect um
maybe what could have um
caused the potential interruption well
you did click through all your slides
correct
in the beginning yes i went through all
of them okay good good just want to make
sure
um that we kind of remove anything else
that could
cause interruption so i think we're good
to go and we can give it another shot so
i'll give you a countdown and then you
can start again
oh from slide one yeah if that's okay
yeah that's fine as long as i know where
where i need to okay not kicking
sure all right wait for the countdown
thank you definitely okay starting
in five four three two
hi my name is sergey sadrakian i'm a
junior faculty at the university of
southern california and children's
hospital los angeles
and i think the organizers for this
invitation and the opportunity to
present
our work today i'll talk about
extracellular vesicles
and chronic kidney disease
so what is chronic kidney disease it is
a
kidney disease defined by gradual loss
of renal function
over sometimes extended period of time
it can be years and
you know many years and there are many
different factors that contribute to
the initiation progression of chronic
kidney disease
in human population the two major ones
being diabetes and cardiovascular
problems in addition obesity
you know genetic mutations tobacco use
aging and other factors as well do
contribute to
progression of chronic kidney disease
i will not be exaggerating if i say that
kidney is one of the most complex organs
in the human body
being that it is very heterogeneous in
in nature
structure wise and very difficult to
study so
so the functional unit of the kidney is
the nephron which is composed of the
glomerulus
and and tubules the glomerulus is a
bolus structure that contains
micro capillaries made up of endothelial
cells and petrocytes
as shown in the diagrams in the right
the podocyte is uh is the is the
is the cell that's uh highlighted in
green that surrounds the capillary
structures and between the
endothelial cells and and protocide is
the
lysine glomerular basement membrane and
in the electron micrographs on the
bottom
you're seeing a projection of the
glomerulus in a
scanning electron microgram actually on
the left and on the right is a close-up
image
where we can more clearly see the
basement membrane
it's a thin layer of matrix and on both
sides
we have the penetrated endothelial cells
and the podocyte
what's so special about this structure
is that nephron cannot be regenerated in
adult life
so we humans are born with specific
numbers of nephrons
and and they are predetermined usually
that number is
roughly somewhere around between 500 000
to 1 million
per kidney
the glomerular cells namely the
pedocytes and endothelial cells
are very unique in their nature the
polar side is unique
because despite the fact that it's a
typical endothelial cell
its location architecture its function
are unique uh because they have this uh
food processes
that make interdigitations at the
filtration barrier
that determine the um permanent
selectivity nature
of the filtration function the polocites
are
post mitotic cells that means they do
not proliferate
they're not they cannot be replaced and
if they do so that means there is a
problem and usually this happens to ring
disease
and they slap off from the basement
membrane which
usually is associated with onset of
protein urea
glomerular endothelial cells are unique
as well because they have
fenestrations and they are responsible
for the first filtration activity
as the ultrafiltrate from the capillary
first has to leave the endothelium then
the basement membrane then through the
pothoside
and lastly the glomerular basement
membrane is unique
and i'm going to highlight this because
this this matrix is
important and plays an important
function in the filtration it's
composed of collagen type 4 in a special
collagen
that is produced only by the podocyte
and mutations in this collagen
or any other component of the matrix
can lead to disease and i'll talk more
about this later
so the homeostatic balance between the
glomerular cells and the glomerular
investment membrane
are important for the maintenance of the
ultrastructural integrity and function
of the of this filtration unit and any
alteration of any of these components
can lead to chronic kidney disease
so the main main treatments
for kidney disease
are hemodialysis and kidney
transplantation
and and we know that loss of glomerular
function
leads to development of uh tyler
hello tyler
yes can can you hear me yes i'm
i'm having a problem uh when i when i
switch the slides
right uh half of my slide disappears
from my screen and so i'm i'm kind of
misled
uh i i don't see everything on my screen
what should i do
every time i click should i click the
next or because i'm using the keys on my
keyboard every time i click my slide
just
slides up on my screen and i don't see
half of it
okay it could be the uh keypad that is
causing a little bit of a glitch so
um if you want to try using the next and
previous
um and see if that works okay for you
sure can i can i can i repeat this last
slide because i i got
tracked off uh because of that yeah this
is like
image four correct yes slide four
okay let me just make a quick note for
it
okay i've made a note so whenever you're
ready
just give it a few seconds and then you
can start again
uh how do i know when to start or it
doesn't matter you just tell me that
yeah just i wait a few seconds a few
seconds of silence and then you can pick
back up
okay sounds good
so uh loss of glomerular function leads
to development of
chronic kidney disease and in the united
states alone there are more than
30 million patients americans who
have the diagnosis for chronic kidney
disease and this is a major burden
financially on the health care system
and
in 2018 alone the estimated cost for
you know ckd treatment and end central
renal disease treatment
was somewhere around 114 billion
so what are some of the treatments
we are not very fortunate because the
only treatments currently available for
patients with renal failure is
either dialysis or kidney
transplantation
so um and and and and the projections
are not
uh looking very good if we look uh
in this graph we can see that uh between
1999 and 2015
the number of transplantations were
relatively constant you know somewhere
around between 17 to 18 000
annually whereas the number of patients
in the transplant waiting list waiting
for a donor organ to have a
transplantation has been growing
um over the years and and this numbers
are even higher
you know currently so
um this is a tabulation of all the
different you know etiologies or kidney
diseases
that lead to eventually
kidney transplantation as you can see
the number is a
number is huge and the conditions range
from
renal cancer to familial conditions
to glomerular uh sclerosis and
uh you know even sickle cell anemia can
lead to uh
kidney disease so the conditions are
enormous
if we take a historical look uh
as to where we stand right now and what
are the opportunities
as i mentioned dialysis and kidney
transplantations are our two main
mainstream therapies for kidney
replacement
but both of these were were discovered
uh
back back in the 1940s and 1950s
and only in 1983 we had the introduction
of immunosuppressants which
really enhanced the success of kidney
transplantations uh
you know providing uh support for the
um you know
against rejection of the transplants
so uh in addition uh treatments for ckd
in addition to
dialysis and transplantation have been
centered on slowing down its progression
by systemic approaches
uh such as using diuretics or ac
inhibitors
which have many side effects and not are
not specifically targeting the
glomerulus
so we are in 2020 now and
no new developments in terms of approved
therapies
um are known and so
some of the areas that the research is
uh
is working on is gene therapy tissue
engineering and regenerative medicine
applications and even some
pharmacotherapy
approaches to to find a new therapy
in addition there is a variety of stem
cells and extracellular vesicles that
have
gained a lot of traction in the recent
years and there seems to be some
opportunity here
for finding a new possible
new possible therapy and so uh
can we our question is can we apply stem
cells or samsung style based
products to target kidney disease
or renal complications
and so over the years we have
took a a specific approach of
using animal stem cells for
potential as a potential therapeutic to
treat kidney disease
and in the past we have looked into
using afscs for treatment of acute
kidney disease as well as
as well as a chronic kidney disease and
we have successfully shown that single
injection of amniotic fluid stem cells
provides renal protection in terms of
morphology and function
as well as survival in these animals and
more recently we have
taken a new approach where we isolated
extracellular vesicles from amniotic
stem cells and we've shown that just
like the afscs
they have they provide similar
protection and in particular we we
observed that uh vcvs
were able to uh protect endothelial
damage
uh induced by vgf signaling in upward
animals and i'll
say a little bit more about this in the
next few slides
so um um just like any other cell affcs
do produce a lot of extracellular
vesicles and we
isolated them using ultracentrifugation
and characterize them
by nanosite and
we can say that afscs produce large
quantities of ebs
so that they can be injected in large
number of animals
so by nanoside we characterized their
size to be roughly about
200 nano meters in diameter
so these evs express typical mesenchymal
markers
extracellular markers such as cd9 cd62b
as well as angiogenic markers such as
vgf receptor 1 receptor 2
so these two receptors are important
for later points that i would like
i will i would make in the in the next
slide in addition
these vesicles also have a large uh
bank of micro rna
both pro angiogenic and anti-angiogenic
and obviously anti-antioxidant
micro rna were detected to be much
higher
and this was important as well
so moving forward i'll introduce
the animal model we used which is alport
syndrome to study ckd
this is a genetic familial disease
that has mutations in the collagen four
off of three four five chains in our
case our model has a mutation in alpha
five chain
which results in abnormal deposition of
the glomerular basement membrane
leading to progressive loss of renal
function and ultimately kidney failure
in this image you are seeing
again an electron micrograph of the
basement membrane and histology
showing normal morphology of the kidney
and upon the mutation in the collagen 4
alpha 5
gene we have a severe disruption in the
basement membrane
as you can see in the projections in the
right and
developing the fibrosis in the
glomerular and tubular compartments
shown by this histology so this leads to
infiltration of immune cells
deposition of cellular matrix scarring
and reduced blood flow
and the reason we are using this new
specific mutation is because 85
of human cases have this specific alpha
phi mutation
so it's a it's a very common whereas the
other mutations are
are much more rare
so in addition we made this interesting
observation that
vgf which is very important for the
maintenance of the glomerular
integrity and specifically the
endothelium and the fenestrations is
highly elevated early on
in alport mice in the glomeruli
and so we were very interested to
understand whether the vesicles which
expressed now which have receptors could
could mitigate this
and so we performed some in vitro
experiments where we
cultured endothelial cells from
glomeruli
and we treated them with regia just to
recapitulate to mimic the conditions
that
exist in the alport glomeruli and
treated them with
normal evs and evs that were
knocked down for regional receptor one
and interestingly we observed that the
the normal leds were able to capture or
bind
to vgf in the media and and
prevent this vgf from being taken out by
the cells
and subsequently we performed some
further analysis
looking into the cells and did some
immune precipitation assays where we
confirmed that
there is a direct interaction between
vgf
and the receptors expressed on the
surface of the evs
so this was important but then um it was
also important for us to understand
whether the evs once injected in in mice
could really
you know home to the kidneys so in
collaboration with dr bisellati in the
university
of torino we uh we performed these
experiments where the evs were injected
in mice and
we could easily detect them in the
kidneys
and and and and image them by
bioluminescence as shown in this
in this figure next obviously
uh was uh also important to understand
whether
they have any uh therapeutic potential
and so we looked at the
you know renal function in terms of
creating an albumin urea
and interestingly with one single
injection
we could see a significant improvement
uh in both of these parameters
so moving forward our ultimate goal was
eventually to
to be able to translate this technology
and so our next steps in
as we move forward we switched from
using old mouse system
where we had the mouse model and using
mouse cvs to a mouse and human hybrid
model
where we now use the still use the same
mouse upwards in your model but
apply human ifsc derived extracellular
vesicles
to understand thereby distribution
therapeutic
effect and mechanisms of action as well
as understand mechanisms of disease
progression
in these animals so
in this you know for this aim we
developed
you know certain um certain directions
namely three specific directions that we
aimed our studies on uh in one direction
we developed
key assays to allow for consistent
characterization of
this human evs now derive from
concentric donors
and evaluate their potential for
clinical you know translation or
application
in the second direction we really
thought about the possibility of
actually expanding these ebays you know
to clinical scale so
we we employed a gmp compatible 3d hello
fiber bioreactor to be able to
meet this need and then
finally we are also developing a
non-invasive clinically applicable
in vivo tracking system for evs using
mri
to evaluate you know potential homing
and associated toxicity
toxicities in undesired of target organs
or tissues
that will eventually combination of
these three approaches will allow
successful you know translation
so looking into the key assays
and there are three of them the first
one is looking at
their identity and purity size
distribution
production and characterization by their
cargo
looking at the protein and micro rna
second assay is the potency assay in
vitro where we look at the
functionality of the evs specifically um
looking at the capability of of these to
trap vgf
as i showed earlier and then lastly look
at their
therapeutic efficacy in vivo where we
isolate glomeruli in injected mice and
look at pgf modulation
analyze gene regulation by rna-seq and
of course functional changes
so we're looking at the the first assay
where we do the identity and purity
uh we we characterize the evs by
nanosite
just like the mouse ones and we
determine their size and distribution
and concentration
we also employed a x exo view
technology where we were able to
visualize
the evs based on their expression of
tetris planning
the cd9 63 and 81 and we can really
this technology allows is a combination
of flow cytometry and
you know immunostore chemistry that as i
said allows visualization
as shown in the right we can you know
see really single single leds and
identify the expression of specific
markers in addition to
tetraspanning and really understand that
heterogeneity so this allows us to
easily characterize
um factorize them so in addition
we looked at surface markers as i said
the cells are coming from concentric
donors so
in this example we're looking at two
samples
clonal clonally derived extracellular
vesicles from two concentric donors
compared to the mesenchymal stem cells
and as you can appreciate these two
independent
consented lines have very similar
expression profile
uh so next uh we
we looked at their protein cargo and
micro rna obviously by
rna sig and mass spec and
in this diagram you are seeing the 10
most highly expressed proteins in micro
rna
i should say that we identify 675
intact proteins in this glomeruli and
2535 microrna were expressed
and these profiles really allow us to to
you know put a fingerprint or on on the
evs that
characterizes or um puts puts an
identity tag
that we we were able to
kind of identify and characterize them
each time we have a new line
uh so uh from our experience we're able
from our experience using the culture
methods and isolation methods and
characterization
methods were able to get consistent lots
of human evs
yielding the same features as
highlighted
so next thing i want to point out is
that when you compare the
our data from the human evs and mouse
uvs there is an 80 overlap in terms of
protein
expression and which confirms the
validity of our derivation method
from the proteome analysis we
in the human sample we also confirmed
the absence of hla dr cd80 and cd86
uh so this is important in terms of uh
immunogenicity
and sequencing rna sequencing also
confirmed
that the humanities do not carry the
major microrna involved in adaptive and
immaculate responses
uh such as mere 24 155 so this is
important as we move as we move forward
using the human eps so our assay number
two
is the potency assay in vitro where
which i talked about for the mice and so
the same was applied here
and the fetal cells glomerulo and the
theta cells were cultured and
[Music]
you know treated with vgf to mimic the
condition that we have in our
globalized and then the human levees
were applied and and
and very similar to what the mao cities
did
uh we were so in another chain of vgf
protein or decrease of egf protein in
this assay
and in the follow-up
or subsequent experiment we we perform
the same
assay without the cells without the
confounding factor of cells and again
we observe the direct interaction
between the vgf and the human evs
uh confirming that the potency
of the human derived evs
being similar if not better than the
mouse
so this was very encouraging and then
lastly
looking at the in vivo efficacy of the
human directvs
in this experiment 2.8
times to the 10 our evs were injected
into the 2.5 months age old upward mice
and as you can see the single injection
significantly improved pgf
activity or activation in isolated
gloomer line
in this example and lastly we also
measured the protein urea in this
animals
and again injection of the human evs
significantly ameliorated protein urea
10 weeks time period after the injection
so moving forward i'll give you a little
bit information about the rna-seq
analysis we performed so mice that were
injected with the evs
and mass that were injected not injected
we
isolated their glomeruli one week after
the injection
and and sent for rna sequencing and this
is the data
that is being projected in this pca plot
as you can see the wild type
samples on the left the anima the
the deceased alport mice with the green
are
you know separating very nicely uh
in this 2d plot whereas the injected
samples shown in blue are really
separating
from both and they are actually
improving at least in one dimension
on the y-axis so this is very
encouraging because we're seeing
uh some effect we performed a lot of
comparative analysis between all the
groups
and to understand and the differences in
similarities and how the injection of
eps
is really changing or shifting the
pathways in
in the glomerular cells and so very
briefly
looking at some pathway enrichment
analysis we identify the key mechanisms
or or you know mechanisms or pathways
that are affected in upward
glomeruli compared to normal and also
looking at the injected animals we now
understand some of the mechanisms that
might be involved in
you know leading to improvement in renal
function and
uh as we look further here i'm showing
just two examples in the lipid
metabolism panel and cell matrix
citation molecules and
shown in red with red dots you can see
the
number of genes that are being modulated
or reversed to normal in this glomeruli
so you know
in addition to lipid metabolism and
matrix citation there are some other
areas
where the evs are are actively um
you know having a positive effect and we
are you know continuously studying these
these mechanisms so next uh
i will talk about the 3d hello fiber
bioreactor
[Music]
studies that we are conducting uh so
we know that ev clinical translation is
limited
by scale up as i said and hello fiber
bioreactor can support culturally large
number of cells at high densities
and can produce large number of dbs and
so in collaboration with
fiber cell systems we are
we are culturing the you know human
consented
afscs and as you can see in this in this
in this figure
i apologize for the you know low
resolution but
the cartridge that's shown in the in the
front is loaded with afscs
and uh and and fed uh
you know by by media and and without
having to passage the cells over a very
long period of time
we can continuously harvest large number
of evs
and and so amniotic food stem cell evs
grown in this cartridge
produce produced by chemically and
functionally equivalent
uh evs uh similar to the you know 2d
derived tvs that we grow in in our
culture room
with yields that can support clinical
scale and gmp
compatible system and so just like with
the 2d
evs growing our you know
lab we perform the same assays for the
reactive derived tvs and as you can see
in this in this figures
the uh the potency assay was not any
less than the 2d derived was even better
and the improvement in proteinuria was
was um much more better than with the 2d
system so
this is very encouraging and we're
looking forward to
to improving this even even further
so next uh i will talk about the uh the
next uh
uh the direction or next uh area we are
advancing
uh or working towards is the is the mri
detection
of evs
[Music]
using um using special dyes or
more specifically iron particles
to study biodistribution and potential
homing and um
you know of target associated toxicities
and etc
and so um mri
is an important modality uh but i before
i go to the mri i should mention that
there are other modalities imaging
modalities uh currently available such
as
optical imaging um through
bioluminescence and
fluorescence imaging nuclear imaging
that they can potentially
uh be used for tracking uh evs in vivo
but they are
you know both of these have certain
limitations
mainly due to the you know safety
concerns because one involves
radio isotopes and optical imaging
requires transfections plasmids and
fluorescent dyes and so
in contrast magnetic imaging or mri
is much safer because it uses only
iron particles and
provides excellent special resolution
that can be used to
identify where the evs are so
in collaboration with this is cell
medical
and that specializes in mri cell and
detracting
technologies we're testing the
possibility of using mri to study by
distribution in viva
so we performed a few for concept
studies demonstrating that a vmi
labeling agent is safe on cells and
ev's production and does not affect
their viability as shown in the first
panel that the label cells or evs can be
detected with electron micro microscope
as shown by the electron dense
projections in panel c and importantly
this
labeling agent does not affect the size
distribution and production levels of
evs
as we confirm with nanoside tracking and
importantly
we can use relaxometry to to measure the
con
the iron content in these vesicles and
importantly
uh the label these can also be uh
visualized with mri
so to test the in vivo tracking
potential of the vmi dye we injected
healthy and controlled mice
with with the evs with a single dose we
are two different routes
uh one was the retro orbital route and
intracardiac route was applied
my mice were imaged once before the
injection
and 30 minutes post post-injection and
as you can appreciate from the
from the from this uh projections a
positive signal was detected only in the
upward mice
injected via the intracardiac route that
is nicely shown in the blow up
projections of the renal cortices in the
right
our mri findings were further confirmed
by tissue histology and as you can
appreciate in this
micrographs persian blue staining is
observed only in the kidney injected
with the endocardia grout
and not through the retro-orbital route
and it's only present in the diseased
tissue and not in the control uh um
control mice so uh intracardiac delivery
of evs to the damaged kidney is more
efficient than iv
route and and we know that that disease
really
uh uh contributes to the homing of the
you know evs or cells uh and to the to
the target organ
and so um this is an important step
moving forward as
uh you know understanding the
biodistribution
homing of any reagent that's being
injected into the human organism
uh is important uh and needs to be needs
to be well documented
so with this i would like to conclude uh
by stating that our protocol
for human evs derivation is reproducible
and allows for derivation of
a large number of ev lots with uh with
similar identity and purity and potency
and that human derived divs shows strong
in vivo you know efficacy uh
as shown by our assays and that the
production of large number of these
using the 3d bio
hollow fiber bioreactor system uh
is similar to uh if not better
than the 2d derived humanities
uh from our culture um you know
laboratory cultures
and that the combination of mri
technology and the vmi
you know tracking system
is a highly applicable technology for
real timing for tracking of evs
that can ultimately shift the paradigm
in
you know in safety and so with this i
would like to conclude and thank
everybody in our
you know research group for their
individual contributions
i would like to thank our contributors
for their uh
for their support and with the
experiments with their ideas
and and you know advice
and ultimately to all our
funding agencies for their support thank
you
i'll take any questions
awesome job well we're all set um i will
do some
quick editing on the front and back ends
um as well as just the
short slide redo when we have the slide
hiccup
and then we'll be ready for the event
next week
sounds good uh was i uh within the 30
minutes
i didn't have any timer to follow
actually
no you were just because we uh did the
restart at the beginning there i know
the
time longer than uh what it actually was
so you're right around
um the 30 minute mark oh awesome great
thanks much um any questions for me
before we wrap up here
um not really so the event is on the
23rd
and this will be available online
thereafter right for some time yeah so
the live event is on the 23rd next week
and then the event will be available on
demand for six months after
oh six months after okay sounds good
well
let me know if anything you went wrong
and uh we need to go over it
uh again i mean any slides any any
any section that doesn't look good
okay that sounds good yeah i'll
definitely reach out if anything does
come up and then if you have
any questions at all depending on the
time of the event feel free to reach out
to me
perfect thank you taylor thank you very
much
have a good rest your day life guys